The September box office got a nice shot in
the arm thanks to the newest adaptation of
Stephen King's It.
Meanwhile, movie fans also got some exciting
new previews for what's to come in the near
future.
From exciting thrillers to clever comedies,
here are the most promising trailers of the
month of September.
The Snowman
The Snowman already had one riveting preview,
but the international trailer offers even
more exciting glimpses at the mystery thriller.
The film follows Harry Hole, a man tasked
with hunting down the elusive "Snowman Killer"
who leaves the childhood playthings as a way
to mark his victims.
And thanks to this new autumn look at the
wintry movie, it's clear that the killer is
playing some serious mind games with everyone,
including reporting his next victim as missing
before he actually abducts her just to make
things even more grisly.
This diabolical move proves the Snowman killer
is even more twisted than ordinary serial
murderers.
Winter is about to come terrifyingly early
on October 20th when this movie lands in theaters.
Tragedy Girls
Social media obsession gets taken to a deadly
new level in the trailer for the comedy thriller
Tragedy Girls.
The movie features two teens who decide to
become crime reporters in an effort to boost
their social media influence.
However, they quickly decide that the best
way to stay on top of the news is to create
it themselves.
You know what comes next — the pair to murder
their classmates, kicking off with a big time
social media influencer.
The girls take well to their newfound fame,
and they get more and more invested in their
killings and the likes that come along with
them.
Count on this one to make you re-think your
digital game starting October 20th.
A Bad Moms Christmas
This sequel to Bad Moms will bring back our
trio of mothers as they take back the holidays
from the world's tough expectations.
The one problem?
They'll also have to contend with their own
mothers, who've dropped in to spread some
Holiday jeers.
"You are a mom.
Moms don't have joy they give joy."
The trailer is full of dirty hijinks, including
a Santa Claus stripper, so prepare for some
naughty list-style fun this season.
A Bad Moms Christmas lands in theaters November
3rd.
Thelma
The Norwegian supernatural thriller Thelma
centers on a new college student who comes
to discover she has supernatural powers she
can't explain.
That might seem like a nice alternative to
gaining the freshman fifteen, but from the
looks of this trailer, those powers will become
terrifying rather than thrilling.
This art house horror flick will hit theaters
on November 10th, just in time for a distraction
from finals.
Cook Off!
A movie many, many years in the making, Melissa
McCarthy's mockumentary Cook Off!
was filmed way, way back in 2006, before the
actress broke out with her Academy Award-nominated
performance in Bridesmaids.
With McCarthy's huge star power, the shelved
film was brought back from the dead and reportedly
re-edited.
Featuring McCarthy as one of the many competitors
in a cooking competition at a local hotel,
the film promises lots of lunacy and delicious
treats when it finally hits theaters on November
17th.
All the Money in the World
Ridley Scott investigate one of the world's
most famous kidnappings in the first trailer
for his upcoming action drama All the Money
in the World.
The movie follows the 1973 abduction of John
Paul Getty III, the grandson of the richest
man in the world.
The movie focuses on the desperate actions
that his mother Gail has to undergo in order
to get him back when her billionaire father-in-law
is unwilling to cough up the cash to get his
grandson back.
The real-life drama here is ripe for the pickings,
and it's exciting to see what Scott and his
all-star cast will do with the story when
it lands in theaters December 8th.
The Shape of Water
The first trailer for Guillermo del Toro's
The Shape of Water was exciting enough, but
this new red band preview is even more incredible.
This new glimpse of the otherworldly fairy
tale shows just how feisty Elisa will be while
protecting the creature she loves.
Although she seemed stoic and innocent in
the first glimpse we saw of the movie, this
new trailer proves Elisa isn't afraid to get
her hands dirty on behalf of her blue lagoon-style
pal.
Considering critics are already hailing this
film, it's clear The Shape of Water will be
a must-see on its December 8th release.
The Disaster Artist
The first trailer for The Disaster Artist
focused on just one familiar moment from The
Room.
But this new teaser about the making of the
worst movie in the world further explores
the relationship between Tommy Wiseau and
his co-star Greg Sestero, played by real-life
brothers James and Dave Franco.
"Stellaaaa"
Count on this movie to be a lot better than
the one it's chronicling when The Disaster
Artist breaks into theaters on December 8th.
Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle
The new trailer for Jumanji: Welcome to the
Jungle proves that sometimes sequels might
not be such a terrible idea.
This new look at the film shows that none
of the characters in the new game will take
to their avatar characters very well in the
new virtual world.
With some laugh out loud moments and a clever
reimagination of the original Jumanji, it
might just be worth it to roll the dice on
Welcome to the Jungle when it arrives on-screen
December 20th.
"I hate this game.
Everybody else got good stuff."
"Weakness, cake."
"yes cake is my weakness"
Downsizing
Matt Damon might be a huge star, but he's
hitting the small time for the upcoming comedy
Downsizing.
The film features him as a man who, alongside
his wife, decides to commit to a new procedure
that shrinks people down until they're five
inches tall.
"Wow, that is wild isn't it?
Just wild."
Consider it a modern, satirical take on Honey
I Shrunk the Kids.
Look for Downsizing to hit the big screen
on December 22nd.
Red Sparrow
Jennifer Lawrence becomes a Russian femme
fatale in the upcoming action-thriller Red
Sparrow.
She plays a ballerina who, after suffering
a career-ending injury, turns to espionage
for a Russian intelligence agency and uses
seduction, violence, and whatever other means
will be necessary to complete her missions
… that is, until she meets an American CIA
operative who might test her loyalty to the
Kremlin.
Considering today's political atmosphere,
this movie will probably be pretty timely
when it bows into theaters on March 2nd.
Tomb Raider
Lara Croft has a new mission in the first
trailer for Alicia Vikander's upcoming Tomb
Raider reboot.
The film features the Oscar winner as the
adventurer as she sets off to find out what
happened to her father, who died while searching
for a tomb located on a mythical Japanese
island.
The trailer hints that the film will draw
heavily from the 10th installment in the game
franchise, which offered up a more complex
take on the character than the releases that
inspired the Angelina Jolie-led movies.
Look for Lara Croft to raid the box office
when the new movie lands in theaters on March
16th.
Hostiles
Christian Bale takes a trip back in time for
the upcoming drama Hostiles, which features
him as an army captain tasked with bringing
a sick Cheyenne war chief and his family back
to their tribal lands in 1892.
From the looks of this preview, Bale may be
putting forward another award-winning performance
in this period drama, so keep your calendar
open for when a release date is announced
for this historic film.
The Lodgers
The haunted house genre gets a gothic twist
in the trailer for the upcoming horror flick
The Lodgers.
The movie features two orphaned twins who
are forced to live in their parents' creepy
former home by a secret curse.
When a young man who's in love with the sister
tries to free the pair, his actions set off
a deadly and terrifying reaction.
With chilling visuals and mysteries aplenty,
this one is sure to draw out some scares when
it's released.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!